adele's first ever instagram life was
chaotic and iconic at the same time oh
i've never done this before see i don't
know how to use all of this when i try
and talk to one of you it's asking me to
join someone else's room i don't know
how to do that do i give you some
instructions it tells me to go in
someone else's room at all that what
room's there hmm that makes me
frightened stranger danger scared about
pressing a button oh oh my dogs just
came who's that come here
my my dogs might poo while i'm talking
too long always i'm on instagram live hi
hello oh there's some questions how do i
do that am i going to collab with peppa
pig now what's my next album going to be
based on divorce babe divorce some of
these questions are wild it's a hot dog
a sandwich i'd say no of course i love
turkey my favorite thing to do during
lockdown was drink wine obviously come
on just cut out my drinking which is
really sad what happened to my eyes i
don't know babe what happened to him
right my makeup routine is just slap it
on and run what's my body count what
does that mean there's so many other
adele's on here wow there's loads of us
crikey there really is loads of us